and he actually looks this way because
he has a condition that removes the
pigment from his skin
he also looks like something else come
on i mean right let's serve up some news
sunny side up so in an effort to get
more people to the polls
there's this young organizer that's
trying the goat out the vote method
okay so mikka mc uh mccutchen
is holding virtual voter rallies from
the middle of this
iowa goat farm like literally she just
you know
she shows you all the goats while she's
giving you information and the goats are
so adorable
people from come for the cuteness but
they stay for the information which i
think is totally adorbs
so you know uh vote with a goat if it
floats your boat
what i did that i just said it and
whether you're 16 or not you can join
americans voting voting in every corner
of this country today and you will be
shocked
where you actually can vote take a look
lifeguard stations people are voting
i love this swimming pool right
hair salons get a new do in a new
country are you ready for this one
num num num taquerias okay yes please
that's what i'm talking about
yeah okay uh what about this a harley
davidson
showroom people are voting there from
vroom
i love this one laundry mat yeah well we
want a clean election drew we do and
that's why people
people are voting everywhere the new
york post reports that the internet is
freaking out
over this surprising creature found in
nepal
check it out it's the rare flapshell
turtle wow this little guy has already
been compared to a wheel of cheese
a cheeseburger uh-huh
and a pancake and he actually looks this
way because he has a condition that
removes the pigment from his skin
he also looks like something else come
on i'm right
people magazine reports that a study
from the university of rochester
found out that watching tv and movies
can
actually make your relationship stronger
it's not just netflix and chilling the
study found that couples who engaged in
conversation after watching a movie
or a tv show saw a 50 reduction in
divorce
compared to a control group it's the
conversation after watching that keeps
you together like
oh my gosh bruce willis was dead the
whole time
i love you honey first up
the story everyone is talking about
about who will be the next president
of the united states george bush
or michael dukakis oh
josie you've missed so much
a lot has happened since 1988. wait
don't tell me don't tell me who what
because my money's on michael dukakis
never underestimate an underdog have you
seen karate kid
yes all five of them
[Music]
you